hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be talking
about what
capital gains tax is when you need to
pay it
and how to avoid paying your capital
gains tax
firstly my name is samuel leeds i've
been in property for over 10 years i've
helped thousands of people
in their property investment journey
i've also written a best-selling
property investment book called buy low
rent high
and capital gains tax is when you buy a
property
the property increases in value and then
you sell it and you've therefore
made a profit and on that profit just
like most profits
you will pay tax and that particular
type of tax is called
capital gains tax now the reason it's
called capital gains tax is because
the capital in your property has gained
value
so the the gained value let's say you
buy a house for 100 grand
and then 10 years later it's worth 200
grand and you sell the house
you have made a hundred thousand pounds
you're gonna have to pay tax on that
money
you're gonna have to pay a fair bit of
tax on that money so you're not gonna be
left with a hundred grand in your pocket
sometimes people don't realize they have
to pay capital gains tax because they
just think well it's an investment
i bought it it went up it's my money but
just the government
always tax you on money that you've made
so it's no different from if you've sold
a product or you've sold a service
you've made money
you've got to pay tax on it now how do
you avoid paying capital gains tax well
the first
obvious way is you get a decent
accountant and you make sure that you
offset losses against your profits so
like in
any business if you've made a profit and
suddenly you're getting taxed on that
profit
you're going to try and find things
where you can say well this was a
business expense and this was an expense
and this was an expense
and you can then knock your profit down
so you've made less
profit so speak to an accountant and see
if you can do that
the second way is if you instead of
selling if you refinance the house
you're still going to make a load of
money from that or not make
and that's this is the great thing this
is the clever thing because
let's say you buy a house for 100 grand
it goes up and it's now worth
200 grand instead of selling it if you
take out a new mortgage
you can refinance it up to its new value
of 200 000 pounds
you're gonna borrow against that and
that money that you take out
you can then invest and you don't pay
any tax on it
zero tax on refinance money i'll give
you an example
so you buy a house for cash hundred
grand it's
uh let's say you don't have a mortgage
on it it's then well and it doesn't
matter if you do or if you don't it then
goes up to two hundred thousand pounds
you sell it you're going to get 100
grand but then you're going to pay a
load of tax
you refinance it you're going to take
out instead of taking out 200 grand
paying a load of tax
you're going to take out probably 75 of
200 grand so you might get 150 grand
you still own the property you don't
sell it you still keep it so you're
continuing making an income from it
you've got 150 grand instead of 200
grand but you don't pay
any tax because that 150 grand is a
mortgage
and a mortgage is a loan is debt and you
can't pay tax on debt
so that 150 grand you can then
invest that into property and you can
you could buy another house for 150
grand
or you could use 150 grand and buy
multiple houses and put down deposits
and you are not paying any tax on that
money which is a really really smart way
to release funds from a property without
paying capital gains tax
the third way to avoid paying capital
gains tax is
if you live in the property you don't
get
capital gains tax on a property that
you've lived in because then it's your
it's your private home
so if you move into a property and you
do it up but you live in it
push the value up and then sell it any
profit that you make
is yours to keep without paying capital
gains tax which is just fantastic so
i would recommend that you speak to an
accountant because i can't give tax
advice i'm not qualified to do that i
can only speak from my experience as a
property investor who's been in the game
now for over a decade i hope you found
this video useful
if you did smash the like button drop a
comment and let me know if you've got
any questions or
let me know what kind of other content
you want you tell me what to make
i'll create the content don't forget to
subscribe you can subscribe
below turn the notification bell on and
i'll see you on the next video thanks
for watching